by the way this whole gas thing you know
what it's doing it's what's crazy with
this one if you can pull up the picture
on this this is a fox news story gas
theft on the rise as gas prices
skyrocketed while gas prices continue to
hit record high some people in southern
california are now resorting to gasoline
theft a fox 11 viewer
shared photos of what happened to a
vehicle a thief drilled a hole in the
fuel tank draining all the gas
aaa seen a rise in gas
siphoning and theft across the country
and now they're warning car owners about
how to keep their vehicles safe this is
a sign of the times you know aaa doug
schupp said it's thieves looking for
ways that they can make money by
stealing what is becoming an
increasingly more expensive and valuable
commodity gasoline mona garcia says
she's fed up with the prices it used to
be sixty dollars then it went to seventy
dollars i think two weeks ago was ninety
dollars so i'm thinking this might hit a
hundred dollars she said while filling
up her car monday as she feared she
spent a hundred dollars to fill up the
tank garcia said her camera and the
floodlight in her driveways uh
the uh any would be thieves uh from
taking gas from the tank pretty crazy
that's getting to a point that people
are now stealing gas from cars this
happened to us my husband and i lived in
california for eight years we lived in
san diego and this was before the
inflation although gas has always been
crazy expensive there he has he has a
project car it's a 1988 camaro iraq z
that he would do projects on and he
parked it in our driveway which was
outside and we came out i think it was
on a weekend he had parked there on a
friday night and we came out the next
morning and there was still like the
tube that the the thief had used to
siphon the gas that was hanging out of
the tank of his guys i i think this is
as much as the red one but it doesn't
have a t-top it's a convertible
uh listen to me talking about these car
terms thank you
uh it doesn't have a t-top it's a happy
end uh
isn't the engine atom it's the top of
the vehicle yeah i know
you know what's crazy here's what's
crazy so you you would think
you
doesn't have a t-top it's a hemi okay
you don't you don't think you don't
think uh uh inflation typically would
cause gas oil what do you call it uh
gold to go up and it hasn't printing
money would cause gold to go up and it
hasn't peter schiff must be furious
right now because oil has gone up and
gold's staying flat it's gone up a
little bit not at the numbers that you
know people are expecting
oil is beating gas folks oil is beating
uh gold uh uh as of right now anyways
are you guys okay if we cover this bio
lab story i don't want to offend you
guys if we go into so what's going on
here with the biola can we do a
last-minute on uh gas real quick you
wanna you wanna say something go ahead
yeah where are the highest state gas
taxes in the nation california there you
go so 22 and a half percent so
sacramento is benefiting or not
benefiting from these high gas prices
they're benefiting thank you very much
yeah by the way you know what they could
do is somebody yesterday i'm trying to
sell this i want to give them credit
somebody said yesterday to me they text
me and they said you know if they really
care about middle america so much all
they have to do is remove the gas taxes
it'll go back down to normal and they
can do that for 90 days but no they're
not going to do because they want the
taxes they want that tax money
yeah california has taken a lot of money
from we take you now to the french
laundry for a comment from gavin newsom
so let me give you a story by reuters
about biolabs and this has been going
back and forth even usa today came out
uh uh talking about which governorship
proposes tax rebate for california's
estate deals with nation's highest gas
prices that's good for him so he's
actually actually wanted to do something
about it good for you uh uh i think
that's a can you can you make that
bigger i want to actually read this on
what he's doing okay they edited the
headline it used to say gavin knew some
comma concerned about midterms comma
proposes tax rebate for california to
see capital government something's going
on yeah make it a little bit bigger than
the democratic government's knowledge on
state union address tuesday night they
came across californians for the price
russia ukraine invasion ukraine hikes
after okay got it newsom said he is
planning to submit a revised budget to
state legislator that would put money
back in california's pockets to address
rising gas prices but he did not
immediately offer any details of how
them okay by the way if he does this we
will give him credit if he does
nationwide the average gas price is
regular gallon reached 417 on monday
breaking a previous record in 20 2008
but in california the average gas prices
are 544 according to aaa that's crazy
that's crazy 544 according to triple a
so if you enjoyed this little segment
from the podcast click over here to
watch the entire podcast and if you've
not subscribed to the channel please do
so take care everybody
[Music]